the Yankees lost last night and now the
Red Sox move on to face the Astros
Michael Kaye was there the Yankee
play-by-play announcer for yes Network
and Michael joins us now well recap what
happened last night and maybe put a bowl
on this season Michael well I mean for
the second straight night I thought that
Aaron Boone was a little bit too slow
taking out the starter it was very very
curious I think both nights they came in
almost like with the NFL does scripting
plays I think they had it scripted when
they were going to go to the bullpen how
many outs they thought they could get
out of the bullpen and after been
intended got hit in the third inning
yesterday I thought that somebody should
get up but you know after the game Aaron
Boone who I thought for the most part
did a really good job in his first
season managing said you know we wanted
to get him through Jackie Bradley jr.
well that was six batters later three
runs later and that was essentially the
game so I think that's gonna be the post
born in the last two games he just he
didn't get the starter quick enough I
mentioned this in the first hour but
I've railed on this before Michael I I
know I sound like the old guy get off my
lawn but it still feels like in the
postseason yeah you have to have that
ability to manufacture a runt like there
has to be these small moments that teams
have and it's gonna play out the you
know the championship series in the
World Series it feels like the Yankees
are there they're certainly built for
the regular season were they built for
the postseason
I had this debate maybe four or five
times throughout the year with Aaron
Boone and it was like away from the
ballpark sometimes or off the record and
I would say the flaw on this team is
that the only way they score is via the
home run and he would take out stats
they have two dads that and they have
stats for everything so it's hard to
argue like arguing with the robot and
then they go well homerun production
actually goes up in the postseason not
down so you're wrong but when you look
at it the last team I think one year one
one team in 33 years has won the World
Series by hitting the most home runs and
that's it
2009 Yankees one and the Yankees always
talk about they have traffic on the base
paths they do they work the count but
you watch that ninth inning yesterday
against Kimbrel the only the way they
were scoring this with a whole month
there was no base hit to right field I
just believe that you've got to be able
to get a base hit every now and then I
want I love the home runs I think that
you know it's great to get three runs on
one swing that goes all the way back to
Earl Weaver but they just don't do a
base hit to right field to score to they
just say they just don't do it Sanchez
almost ended out that would have been a
great cleanse of his season and you know
you're waiting on Giancarlo Stanton to
do it man and he strikes out that's the
only way they really know how to score
but they insist that that can win in the
postseason Dan I seen it since the last
since 2001 they won the World Series
all those 2003 2004 2005 teams they had
a lot of home runs and they got knocked
out in the playoffs every single time
because I truly believe that great
pitching will stop you from hitting home
runs yeah and I look at the Red Sox and
the influence of of Cora on this roster
after coming over from Houston because
Houston was a strikeout team a few years
back and they put the ball in play now
they still hit home runs everybody does
but I I saw some influence from the
Astros on these Red Sox and now you have
these two teams clashing handicap what
you think will play on the ALCS one at
four so you could you can obviously hang
up on me in terms of how much I know but
I think the Astros are on the roll but
they're pretty special I think their
starters are better than the Red Sox I
think they'll line up is you know kind
of equal to the Red Sox but they've got
guys that have been there and done that
so yeah they make contact they don't
strike out as much and I'll take the
Astros I think the winner of this series
gonna win the World Series as far as
what the Yankees do in the offseason I'm
looking at the pitching staff I know you
still tied up with Sabathia a couple
more years right no no you're done oh
you are yeah he wants to come back but
they have to decide
whether or not they want to bring them
back oh okay
so what's the big-ticket item what are
they shopping for in the offseason
I would think Corbin from Arizona I
think you know as much as we look at
analytics in the bullpen and how
important it is the reason the Red Sox
won this series Dan is they got better
starting pitching and that allowed that
one scorer to make decisions more to
leisurely pace rather than you know have
to pull a starting pitcher early when
when they did get to a starting pitcher
that's when the Yankees won Game two so
I think they're gonna have to improve
that now the big question is going to be
that we've had house timer on my radio
show a number of times and he has said
you know the one of the keys of this
year was to get under the salary tax
threshold so they accomplished that so
they reset the number and a lot of
people think they might go out now and
just spend big again because they reset
the number but star burners told me over
and over he says I don't think you have
to have an over 200 million dollar
payroll to win a World Series but if
they decide ok it's been 2009 since we
won now let's just go out and spend I
mean they can get Harper they can get
Machado they certainly have the money
for that they can make those big ticket
items sort of purchases or they can
continue on the path of development
within their system bring up a justice
Sheffield things like that and even if
they decide to be somewhat prudent and
going the free agent market I still
think that they will go after a guy like
Patrick Korbin and that will soar to
find the rotation because they knew they
need starting pitching the temperature
on your radio show when it comes to the
Giants with Eli and Odell Beckham jr.
where do the fans you think stand in New
York on all of this you know what I
think it goes down according to age
young people seem to like Odell Beckham
jr. the older people do not like Odell
Beckham jr. I guess I fall into that
latter category a guy get off the lawn
in this case because I just thought what
he did in that interview with Joe Cena
Anderson it's not needed you know that's
not leadership that's not what you do
and Eli Manning certainly takes the high
road now most people will talk about Eli
you know we're split down the middle on
that you know he gave us two Super Bowls
and
you know why knock him or he's done so I
think that split but I'd say the
majority people thought that what Odell
did the other day on Sunday was wrong
good to visit with you Michael thanks
for joining us we appreciate you time a
zone thank you buddy that's Michael K
Yankee broadcaster for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]